- Emeritus of obstetrics, gynecology
and reproductive sciences
at the University
of California, San Francisco
School of Medicine.
Retired from practice in
September, I didn't know that,
after a 34 year career
as a clinician educator
of OBGYN and primary care residence
at San Francisco General Hospital.
And since 2015, he's
been a clinical fellow
for the National Family Planning
and Reproductive Health Association,
providing advice on clinical issues
and reproductive health policy,
and I got his clinical
opinion at lunchtime.
So Dr. Policar is gonna talk to us
about contraception and other topics.
Dr. Policar.
- Thank you.
(applause)
Nice to actually be back in this room,
it's been quite a while.
Thank you for the
invitation, and you've heard
a little bit about my
connection to this issue
of family planning and menstrual issues
as they come up for women with
a variety of disabilities.
At our clinic, at the San
Francisco General Hospital,
our women's health center on 5M,
we were oftentimes a referral site
for women who had a variety of conditions
where they needed a gynecology consult,
and we assisted in making the decisions
about whether to use hormones
or not and IUD or not,
what type and so on.
So that is mainly the perspective
that I'm going to bring to you today,
as well as kind of what's new in the world
of family planning so
that you can think about
how to apply that to your patients.
However, before I jump in and get started,
whenever I talk about contraception,
sometimes when I talk about
it, everyone (mumbles).
I like to tell you about my bike team.
So there are a number of us
at the San Francisco General
in the OBGYN department who have ridden
in the Waves to Wine,
which is a fundraiser
for multiple sclerosis.
We've done that for 10 years, we've raised
almost a million dollars in doing that.
But I thought you'd be really interested
in the name of our bike team.
(audience laughter)
So that is the actual back of our jersey.
We're pretty well known
between here and Santa Rosa,
which is the termination
of the Waves to Wine.
Our bike team even has a team motto.
We are the best bike team period.
(audience laughter)
So I'm gonna be talking
about family planning,
and we, you know, most of
the folks in the picture
are my family planning colleagues
at San Francisco General,
and also talking a lot about bleeding.
But before I jump into
that, I wanna tell you
about our go-to guidelines, the Centers
for Disease Control, over the last decade,
has developed some incredibly helpful
evidence-based guidelines when
it comes to family planning.
And there are two in particular
that we use every day.
And the reason that I tell you about them
is that some of the sections in both
of these different
guidelines have to do with
the safety and the efficacy
of contraceptive methods
in women who have a variety
of chronic medical conditions,
disabilities or sometimes both.
The first and most important is called
the CDC Medical Eligibility Criteria,
its most recent update
was a couple of years ago.
And it mainly looks at safety,
so tells us about 10 or
11 different categories
of contraception, and
then 60 different kinds
of chronic conditions and the safety
of using a contraceptive for each,
a particular contraceptive
for each of those conditions.
One of the reasons I tell you about it
is that I'm going to be
using the MEC grading system
as we go through three
different case studies.
But the way that this works is that,
if it's MEC category
one or two, basically,
it is safe to use a particular
method of contraception
for a woman who has the specified disease.
If it's a category three, it means that
sort of an equal balance
of benefit and harms,
but always it's safer to use
the method of contraception
than it is to become pregnant.
And then the fours are the ones
where we avoid a particular
method of contraception
when a woman has an
underlying medical condition,
just because the risk
of the method is more,
is clearly more harmful than it is
for her to use it, sometimes even more
than the risk of pregnancy.
But you'll see those numbers
again in just a moment.
The other document that's important
is called the Selected
Practice Recommendations
for Contraceptive Use,
originally published
in 2013, but updated in 2016.
That is much more oriented towards
each individual method,
about when to start,
when to stop, specifically
how to use the method
and then using it in very
specific circumstances.
So laid out in a slightly different way,
but equally helpful.
Now, the important thing is that,
with your tax dollars at work,
the CDC actually put together
a wonderful app that combines both
the medical eligibility criteria
and the selected practice recommendations.
It's completely free and the way to get it
in the Apple Store or
in the Google Play Store
if you have an Android
phone is just to type in
the search term CDC and contraception.
You can download this, and it's just
an incredibly helpful tool to have
when you're thinking about
what method of contraception
might be the most
appropriate for your patient.
And I know that our residents
at San Francisco General,
most of the family planning people
that I work with just
constantly refer to this
as our evidence-based database
about safety and efficacy
of various methods of contraception.
So what I've done, and
based on the literature,
this wasn't entirely my
idea, is to put together
an algorithm that has to
do with two separate issues
that we might deal with in women
who have developmental disabilities.
One is menstrual period, periods, rather,
and irregular menstrual bleeding
and how to get that under control.
The second is the issue of whether or not
that person needs a
method of contraception.
And then we can basically
put together a matrix
that puts people in the
category of either having
bleeding problems or not,
needing contraception or not.
But it looks like this,
that it starts with
a woman comes in for a visit
with her primary care provider
or a woman's health visit
in a family planning clinic
or with an OBGYN.
We ask about her sexual activity,
her menstrual pattern and hygiene.
And let's say that she does
disclose or her caregiver
discloses that she is having problems
with menstrual regularity,
maybe very heavy
menstrual periods that
are problematic for her.
The next question is, is
she also sexually active?
And if the answer is yes, there are
specific contraceptive methods
that I'll go through
with you in more detail
that will both reduce your bleeding,
as well as give her very
effective contraception.
On the other hand, she may
have menstrual problems,
but she's not sexually active yet,
and contraception is not at the forefront.
So there's a slightly different list,
and we'll talk about using NSAIDs as a way
of getting menstrual
bleeding under control,
and then some of the other
hormonal methods you see
would be used less for contraception,
but more for menstrual cycle control.
On the other hand, we have women
who are not complaining
of menstrual problems
who have regular periods,
or the amount of bleeding
that they have is not
problematic for them.
If they're sexually active, they can use
just about any method of contraception,
with one or two exceptions
that I will cover.
For example, using oral contraceptives
or a patch or a ring in a woman
who also has a problem
with a seizure disorder
because of the possibility of interactions
with her antiepileptic medication
and the use of pills, patch or ring.
And then the last part
of that two by two table
is women who don't have menstrual problems
and who are not sexually active yet.
And in that circumstance, of course,
none of these hormonal approaches
would be appropriate at this time
until she discloses that she is interested
in becoming sexually active.
Now, you may have noticed the asterisk
that was present on the question about
do you need contraception or not,
and Erica has done a really nice job
of how to have those initial conversations
about whether you are
sexually active, if not,
whether you're thinking about
becoming sexually active.
So the way we would
start in our OBGYN clinic
is to assess her capacity
to consent to having sex.
And if she was having
non-consensual intercourse,
then, of course, we would be
working with her caregiver
and probably going through the
process of reporting abuse.
But on the other hand, if she was having
consensual sexual activity,
the kinds of topics
that we would be covering
would have to do with intimacy
and safety issues, physical
safety issues with her partner.
Number two, whether there's a possibility
of having acquired a sexually
transmitted infection.
Screening for that, of course,
treating for it if it's
needed, as well as providing
some amount of education
about STD prevention.
A slightly different conversation
about choosing a method
of contraception for many patients.
That is a much more detailed conversation
based on shared decision making about
going through the whole menu
of contraceptive methods
and asking the question of
what are you really looking for
in a contraceptive method.
Not what method do you
want, but what do you want
in a method, which is really
a much more important question
in helping people to decide
which method she would like
to be able to use.
However, the kinds of things that
we're certainly gonna
cover in this discussion
is what are the available
methods of contraception,
the pros and cons of ones that
might be most appropriate.
Of course, the issue of informed consent,
whether that can be done
by the patient herself
or whether there's a
guardian or a caregiver
that would help her with that,
and instructions regarding the correct
and consistent use of the method.
And then always, always
agreeing to a follow-up plan
so that, if she's having bleeding or pain
or other problems, that we
can address that promptly.
So let's start with the
first of our three patients,
she's Jena, 19 years old,
she was born prematurely
at 26 weeks, she had a
birth weight of 1,100 grams.
She has both visual and
hearing difficulties
since childhood, which
may have been related
to her very low birth
weight and the months
that she spent in ICU.
She now also has mood problems,
she complains of irregular
heavy menstrual periods.
Dysmenorrhea means that her periods
are also quite painful and crampy.
In general, would really
like her periods to stop
if at all possible.
She is sexually active
with a 19 year old male,
and she feels safe and
comfortable in that relationship.
On physical exam, her body
mass index or BMI is 34,
so she's somewhat overweight,
her blood pressure is normal,
she has mild facial hirsutism.
So when you put together
both her body weight,
as well as her regular
periods and her facial hair,
you think about chronic anovulation
or polycystic ovary syndrome as a reason
for her irregular menstrual periods.
So with Jena, we have two
things that we wanna address,
hopefully at the same time.
Number one is to address her complaint
about her heavy and irregular
periods, and number two,
the fact that she's sexually active
and wants protection against pregnancy.
So here we are in this
part of the algorithm
where she does have menstrual problems,
she is sexually active.
And the most appropriate approaches
would be a Levonorgestrel
Intrauterine System or IUD;
DMPA, which is Depo-Provera;
extended cycle oral
contraceptives; or POP,
stands for progestin-only
birth control pills.
Before we actually get to those methods,
I wanna just preface that with a few other
just quick remarks, and
then we'll talk about
how we're going to manage Jena.
One is, what are the variety of things
that are available to us
in terms of helping her
with her heavy and irregular
periods, and this comes from
a really nice clinical practice guideline
written by the American
Congress of Obstetricians
and Gynecologists a few years ago
called Menstrual
Manipulation of Adolescents
with Physical and
Developmental Disabilities.
I think it's the best
guideline written in the US
on that particular topic.
So they first point out
that we can use hormones,
sometimes even NSAIDs as a
way of making bleeding less,
less frequent, later, but it's difficult
to actually completely
stop menstrual periods.
But at least we can make
them way less frequent
and way less heavy.
Number two is that a non-hormonal approach
is to use NSAIDs, that they
decrease ovulatory or even,
for that matter, anovulatory
menstrual bleeding
by at least a third.
And I didn't put it into your handout,
but I knew I'd get a question about okay,
which NSAID are you talking about?
And the actual go-to NSAID
that we use to try to decrease
both menstrual bleeding
and menstrual cramps
is naproxen sodium in a
dose between 220 and 440 BID
twice a day during the
period of menstrual bleeding,
that there's good evidence
that naproxen sodium
actually works significantly
better than Ibuprofen
in women to decrease
crampy menstrual periods.
But of course, if that's not
available as Aleve or one
of the over the counter
naproxen sodium preparations,
then Ibuprofen also
works not quite as well,
but it's gotta be given
in an intermediate dose
of 400 to 600 milligrams
three times a day,
but only during her menstrual period,
only during the time that she's bleeding.
She won't need it for
the rest of the month
in order to anticipate bleeding.
And then the ACOG guideline also mentions
that we can give oral
contraceptives every single day,
what's called continuous
combined oral contraceptives,
over an extended period,
and I'll be telling you
more about that in a few minutes.
Progestin-only pills, which are,
only one type is available
in the United States,
but that's one that
may go over the counter
in the next few years.
Works well as a method of contraception,
the one problem is the fact
that it's gotta be taken
at the same time every day.
So if a person is in a living situation
where they may not be able to have
the consistency of a daily pill
at the same time every day,
then this is a method that
might actually eventuate
in some amount of breakthrough bleeding.
DMPA, you may know that
as a Depo-Provera shot
that's given every 12 weeks.
Not only works really well
as a method of contraception,
but it has a tendency to
completely stop periods
and induce amenorrhea by the fourth dose,
and it very commonly is used for women
who have sort of more extreme
developmental disabilities
where the idea is to try
to completely dry out
menstrual periods if we can do that.
The ACOG guideline also points out that
the levonorgestrel IUD,
you may know that one
by its trade name of
Mirena, but there are now
four different levonorgestrel IUDs,
are also a very very good choice,
because they also induce
amenorrhea, as well
as being remarkably effective
as a method of contraception.
Which now brings up the
question of efficacy.
In the family planning
world for the last 10 years,
we have thought of
efficacy in three tears.
Top tier are the methods that work so well
that there's less than one pregnancy
per 100 couples per year.
And those are mainly
contraceptive implants,
one implant that goes under
the arm called Nexplanon.
Any of the IUDs and tubal
occlusion or tubal ligation
that we won't discuss
today in our patients.
Middle tier are the methods
that have a failure rate
between 6 and 12 pregnancies
per 100 women per year.
And those are drugs like Depo-Provera,
the pill, the patch, the
ring and the diaphragm.
And then the bottom tier,
with more than 18 pregnancies
per 100 women per year,
are barrier methods
and natural family planning.
So in general, while it's
not the sole determinant
of the most appropriate
method for a woman,
if efficacy is really important
to her, then of course,
we'd like to go in the
direction of using one
of the top tier methods.
So for Jena, here are
the sort of pros and cons
of each of the methods
that are available to her.
A levonorgestrel IUS or
IUD is tier one efficacy,
it works extremely well.
Its advantage is that,
among the various products,
there's one that works for three years,
many of them are FDA
labeled for five years,
the evidence says that they
actually work all the way
for seven years.
So in particular, if a woman, let's say,
needs to go to a surgery
center to have an IUD inserted,
you'd like to choose one that she can use
for the longest period of time,
and even though Mirena, LILETTA,
some of the others are
labeled for five years,
we know that they work for at least seven,
probably even longer.
As well as stopping menstrual periods,
they also decrease pain
of menstrual periods,
dysmenorrhea as well.
The disadvantage is that
there are some women
with developmental problems
who may not tolerate
insertion of the IED in
an outpatient clinic,
I'm gonna give some ideas
about how that could be done.
But if not, it's much better, I think,
to do it under conscious sedation,
either in a special clinic
or in a surgery center.
And as well, there might initially be
some breakthrough
bleeding, it has a tendency
to clear up fairly quickly.
Next is DMPA or
Depo-Provera, it doesn't work
quite as well as IUDs.
Its advantages are one
shot every 12 weeks,
so that means only four
times a year, basically,
a little over four times a year.
Great job of reducing bleeding
and pain of menstrual periods.
But one of the things you
may have heard about it
is that it can cause weight gain,
particularly in adolescents.
So if weight gain is an issue,
maybe for someone who's already
on the obese side like Jena,
it might not be the best approach.
Next is extended oral contraceptives,
and what that refers to is remember
that birth control pill
packs are 21 days of hormones
and then seven days of
a hormone-free interval,
seven days off during which (mumbles)
have a menstrual period.
But extended OCs means
using an active pill
every single day.
One approach is to do
that for 84 days in a row
and then have a 7 day menstrual period,
that means you'll have
four periods a year.
Another approach is one
pill a day every single day
all year, just no break, basically,
and therefore, no periods.
That works really well for contraception
and really well for menstrual suppression,
as long as you can remember
to take your pill every day.
And with progestin-only pills,
I would say that that's
not as good a choice,
because number one, it's
tier two in efficacy
and it has somewhat more
breakthrough bleeding,
it's important to remember
to take it every day
at exactly the same time.
But one of its advantages is that
it has no estrogen-related side effects.
So there are some women
who would like to use
the pill, patch or ring, but maybe because
they've had a DVT or a pulmonary embolism
or they don't like
estrogenic side effects,
that they can use one of these methods
that has progestin only,
and then not have to deal
with the side effects of
something which is estrogenic.
So bottom line is that for Jena,
we have quite a number of
alternatives for her, both
for contraception and to get
her bleeding under control.
And I think most OBGYNs would tell you
that the ideal approach for her,
from our point of view, of course,
it's ultimately her decision, it would be
a levonorgestrel IUD
because of its efficacy
and inducing either
light menstrual periods,
which are hypermenorrhea or amenorrhea,
they work remarkably well.
And it takes virtually no input
from the patient herself
once the IED is in place,
so it's what's called
forgettable contraception.
So they have the IUD inserted
or the implant put in,
and then you simply don't have to worry
about your birth control
method for the next
anywhere between three
years and seven years.
The challenges, of course, as I said,
are a woman's ability to
tolerate a pelvic exam
in the outpatient clinic, if not,
needing to go to a place where she
can have conscious
sedation to have that done,
and not only the exam, but
then the procedure itself
of putting it in.
So I added a few slides about the wisdom
that we've learned from a
variety of sources and ACOG
and others about the pelvic exam itself
in women who have a
variety of disabilities.
And this one is something that I'm sure
all of you live every day.
We need some reminders sometimes
in the world of women's
healthcare that the women,
woman herself is the one who
entirely guides the exam.
And what we have to do first is to ask her
how she wants to be examined,
what position works best.
Do you have any suggestions
for how we do this?
And of course, for me, it's not only true
as it relates to, let's
say, doing an IUD insertion,
but I do a lot of colposcopy for women
who have abnormal pap smears,
and significant number
of women who were referred to us,
let's say, for example, in a wheelchair.
And so always, my first question is
what works best for you in terms of
how we can transfer you to the exam table?
What's worked best for you when you have
a speculum inserted in your vagina
so that we can have a look
with a colposcope, for example.
It's virtually never our
decision as clinicians,
98% of the time, our patient
can tell us what's worked,
what hasn't, and then we
follow her instruction,
so it's a matter of ask,
ask, ask in advance.
And she has control.
Can you lift the sheet so
that I can start the exam?
Asking permission before
each step in the exam,
especially for someone who's
had sexual trauma in the past.
Always lift the table
up so that she can see
what's going on instead of being supine
or flat on the table, we
offer our patients a mirror
so that she can look at
her vulva if she'd like to,
and then bearing down with
the insertion of the speculum.
So they're all the mini tricks
that we can do to help with the exam.
Then another part of that is
a very thorough inspection
on the outside because of the possibility
of sexual abuse or self-mutilation.
By the outside, of
course, I'm talking about
on the initial inspection of the vulva.
And then remembering about
temperature instability
in some people and trying
to keep the room warm
and offering a blanket to
be able to keep her warm.
Now, I mentioned that, with Jenna,
she had some problems since childhood
with both vision and with hearing.
So there are some things that
we specifically try to do
in our clinic with patients
who are vision impaired,
and that's particularly
important in terms of
where the helper, whether
that's a medical assistant
or someone that she's
brought with her will be
to be able to sort of explain to her,
close to her ear, what's going on.
We offer the opportunity of
feeling the speculum in advance,
and of course, being very clear about
what we're doing step by step.
And for the hearing impaired patient,
we wanna know where her interpreter,
if she needs someone to help with signing.
We'll sit, usually it's sort of a triangle
between the clinician who's
at the end of the exam table,
the person who's doing the sign language
and the patient yourself, but you can see
in this graphic about the
fact that she's sitting up,
which is a really important part
of being able to do this exam,
and by the way, it does not
impair your ability to do
a speculum exam at all.
All right, now, the
last part of it then is
are there any things that you can do
to kind of help patients
with the discomfort
that they may have, especially
in the circumstances
that Erica was talking about a moment ago
where someone may be
hypersensitive to pain,
just the least amount of touch
is enough to feel painful.
So we use a lot of
what's called verbicaine.
I'll tell you more about
verbicaine in just a second,
it just means talking to
people through their procedure,
whoops, and distraction.
Moving slowly, sometimes
using a local anesthetic
at tenaculum side, we're
doing cervical block.
Occasionally, we'll do oral
sedation in the office,
but when we think that the
patient's not gonna be able
to tolerate that very well,
we'll use conscious sedation
in a surgery center.
And then there's some controversies,
particularly with IUDs,
about whether or not pre-medication works.
NSAIDs probably don't help
very much with the procedure,
although they help with
the cramping afterwards.
And there's a medication
called Misoprostol,
you may know of it as Cytotec,
which dilates the cervix and softens it.
That's mainly in women who are pregnant.
And in non-pregnant women,
doesn't seem to help as much,
and there are six different studies
that look at it as a way of
helping with IUD insertions,
it doesn't increase the success rate,
it doesn't make the pain any less,
so we don't use it for that purpose.
But verbicaine's important.
Keep her talking.
Calm, soothing vocal
tone, a slow, easy pace.
I'll talk to her about how
are the (mumbles) doing,
tell me about where you live, the weather,
just a variety of things that help.
And we love cell phones.
And what I mean by that
is if I've got a patient
who's having colposcopy
or having an IUD inserted
and she's texting on her cell
phone, I could not be happier.
(audience laughter)
Just because of the fact that it is
a great form of
distraction, and of course,
I'll tell her what's going on, but
that's a way of self-medication,
and it usually will work very well.
Now, just to finish up with Jena,
Jena decided to have an IUD placed,
but she missed her appointment.
So she called and stated
that she had unprotected sex
with her boyfriend two days ago
and didn't use a method of contraception,
and she asked about
the morning after pill.
And this obviously may come
up in other circumstances
where one of your clients
has hopefully consensual sex,
but wasn't protected and asks you
about emergency contraception.
So there are two different kinds
of emergency contraceptive pills
that I will tell you about.
And we can also use a copper IUD,
which is actually, by far and away,
the most effective approach
to emergency contraception.
So the one that's been
out for the longest time
is a levonorgestrel
emergency contraceptive pill.
It is a single dose tablet,
you may have heard it
referred to as Plan B.
It's supposed to be used within three days
of unprotected intercourse.
And it works reasonably well as long as
you give it within three days,
you can actually use that
all the way up to five days,
but there's kind of a drop off
between 72 hours and 120 hours.
And as I mentioned, Plan B is the generic,
I'm sorry, the brand name version,
there are many many generic versions
that are available in pharmacies now.
And you may have heard, remembered
that two tablet versions
of Plan B, or even using
birth control pills as
emergency contraception.
Those are now considered to
be completely out of date.
It's just a single tablet.
The other form of emergency contraception
is called ulipristal acetate, UPA.
So it prevents ovulation even right before
that egg is ready to leave the ovary.
And it prevents implantation
of a fertilized egg,
although a much higher dose
of ulipristal is required.
It's taken as a single 30 milligram dose.
And it's labeled all
the way up to five days
from the day of unprotected intercourse,
and there's a single product
out there called Ella
and it has to be prescribed.
And I've already mentioned
that a copper IUD
can be used within five days
of unprotected intercourse.
It is an off label use,
but widely performed.
And it's a very cost effective approach
for the person who needs
both emergency contraception
and then a longer term method
of contraception as well,
and it works for a full 10 years,
according to the package labeling.
It actually works longer than
that, probably up to 12 years.
Now, an important question
is how can your patient
get a supply of emergency contraceptives,
and the answer is is that,
with levonorgestrel pills,
they've been available
over the counter for years,
there are no age restrictions.
Men and women can buy them, a person
doesn't need to show an ID that has
anything to do with their age.
The price range is anywhere
between $40 and $50.
On the other hand,
ulipristal acetate or Ella
does require a prescription.
The good news is is that, as part of
the Affordable Care Act,
women who have Medicaid,
who have commercial
insurance, are entitled to
18 different methods of contraception,
including emergency contraceptive pills,
without any cost sharing.
Thing is is that, in
order for the health plan
or Medi-Cal to pay for the
emergency contraceptive pills,
either type, prescription
has to be written,
that's mainly for bookkeeping purposes.
But there are no out of pocket costs
for emergency contraception, as long as
you're able to have a prescription for it.
If you just buy it over the counter,
then it may be that your health plan
won't pay for it in that circumstance.
One last thing to mention
about emergency contraception,
and we'll go to our next patient,
is there is a relationship between
a person's body weight
and the likelihood that
the emergency contraception will fail.
So remember, with Jena,
her BMI was over 30, okay.
So basically, this algorithm is
a patient asks for
emergency contraception.
We counsel her about whether or not
she'd be interested in a copper IUD.
If she's not, then the next question
is what's her BMI, her body mass index.
If she's got a BMI of under 35,
any of the emergency contraceptive options
are both acceptable and efficacious.
If she's a little overweight,
which is a BMI of 26 to 29,
the levonorgestrel is less effective
than the ulipristal acetate.
For a BMI of 30 to 34, there's no question
that the levonorgestrel doesn't work
nearly as well as ulipristal.
And many of us feel that
it shouldn't even be used
in a person who has a BMI of over 30,
I would be way more in
favor of using ulipristal
with Jena than I would
be using levonorgestrel
because of her body weight
and the likelihood of failure.
And then, for women who
have a BMI of over 35,
neither of them work.
And in that circumstance,
you really have to
use a copper IUD if you wanna
do emergency contraception,
'cause its efficacy has no
relationship at all to weight.
All right, well, that's
what we'll do for Jena.
The next patient is Paula.
So she is a 24 year old woman who has
autism spectrum disorder.
She's virginal, she has no
interest in sexual activity.
But she does have unpredictable menses
and an aversion to
changing her menstrual pads
and she doesn't even wanna try tampon use.
Given the fact that she's
never had intercourse,
she's not comfortable putting a tampon in.
She's not had her first
pelvic exam, her BMI is 22.
Her blood pressure is normal.
And now we have two challenges
in regard to Paula, number one,
she's really interested in her
menstrual periods stopping.
Doesn't need birth control.
And the question comes up for
this 24 year old virginal woman,
does she need to have a pelvic exam
in order to have her first pap smear,
her first cervical cytology?
So she fits in this part of the algorithm,
where she does have menstrual problems,
she's not sexually active, and
these are our four choices,
some of which we've already talked about.
So NSAIDs by themselves will
decrease her flow and her pain.
The only side effect are
some of the GI issues
of stomach irritation
that come up with NSAIDs.
So that may be all she needs, basically.
A levonorgestrel IUD
can potentially make her
entirely amenorrheic, but again,
we've got issues regarding placement.
Depo-Provera will do the same thing
when we're not so
worried about weight gain
in her circumstance because
she's slender already.
But that's another alternative in terms of
completely stopping her periods.
Or, again, she can go
with extended continuous
oral contraceptive use every day
as a way of stopping
her menstrual bleeding.
So any of those are
reasonable choices for her.
But in her circumstance, given the fact
that she's virginal, has
an aversion to having
anything like put into her vagina,
maybe isn't ready for
her first pelvic exam.
I think in her circumstance,
probably the optimal approach
is continuous extended
oral contraceptives.
And in that circumstance,
there's simply no reason
to insist that she have
a pelvic exam performed.
Because it will give quite
effective suppression
of her menstruation if she's
able to take a pill every day.
It's more forgiving or a
missed pill than cycling,
which means that, if she did
need it for birth control,
when you're taking a pill every single day
and then miss it for a day or two,
you're unlikely to ovulate.
Consistent every day pill taking
may be relatively easy or hard,
depending on her circumstances.
No need for a pelvic examination,
but her challenges will be to remember
to take a pill every single day.
Initially, acceptance of
breakthrough bleeding,
which happens, usually,
for the first month or two
of continuous birth control pills.
And then sometimes, there are problems
with getting a health plan, even Medi-Cal,
to pay for a whole year,
16 cycles, basically,
of oral contraceptives.
They're very used to paying for 13 cycles,
they sometimes balk at the extra three.
And the way to get around
that is really easy.
You write a Medi-Cal TAR and say
I need continuous birth
control pills for this patient
and I need 16 cycles a
year, and the Medi-Cal TAR
field office will almost always say yes,
as long as you explain why you
need it in that circumstance.
Now, one last thing to mention
about her circumstance is,
does she need to have a first pap smear?
So let me just take a
side bar for a second
and talk about cancer screening in women
who have developmental disabilities.
And the first one is
specifically related to cytology,
what I'm gonna tell you
about breast cancer screening
and ovarian cancer screening
relates to everyone.
So in virginal women, and
that's defined as a woman
who's never had penetrative
vaginal intercourse,
the risk of dysplasia,
which is a precursor
to cervical cancer, is extremely low.
But it's not zero.
So if you compare that to women
who have had heterosexual
contact or who have had sex
with women where the risk
is probably somewhat less,
and women who have never
had penetrative sex,
we've known for 500 years that their risk
of cervical cancer is very low.
But it can still happen,
it's just extremely rare
in that circumstance, okay.
Now, most, I'm sorry,
it's missing a G there,
it should say most recent
guidelines are silent
on whether or not virginal women
should have a cervical cytology or not.
There was an ACOG guideline
that was published in 2010
that said that, for
women who are virginal,
irrespective of their
age, we should talk about
the pros and cons of screening
and leave the decision to
them as a shared decision.
What I usually tell
virginal patients is that,
again, your risk of cervical cancer
is really low, it's not zero.
It's perfectly reasonable if you do want
a cervical cytology, but
if you wanna postpone that
until you start sexual activity,
that is absolutely as reasonable a choice.
And the guidelines would
say that as well, whoops,
wrong direction.
Next question is what about
breast cancer screening?
You know, this is an
area of great controversy
at the moment, but basically,
the American Cancer Society
says that clinical breast
exam is not recommended
for women of any age.
So a woman comes in
for a well woman visit,
disabled or not, ACS is
saying there's no evidence
to support doing a screening
breast exam for those women,
I think they got it exactly right.
Even ACOG is now saying
that that should be
a shared decision about
whether or not a woman decides
that she wants to have a
breast exam done or not.
Now, this, of course, is a screening exam,
not a diagnostic exam
if you have breast pain
or a breast lump, that sort of thing.
And the mammography guidelines, of course,
are the same for all women.
All the guidelines say
basically start at 50,
but that women between 40 and
49 should be given information
about their pros and cons and be able
to make their own choice.
Finally, what about
ovarian cancer screening?
And there's quite a
vigorous debate out there
about the value of screening pelvic exams.
We are unquestionably
going in the direction
of abandoning the screening pelvic exam
in women who have no
symptoms, in women of any age.
That it almost certainly
does more harm than good,
it's uncomfortable, there are
way too many false positives
and it doesn't change any outcomes at all.
So if someone were to say okay, well,
our patient doesn't need a pap smear,
but doesn't she need a bimanual exam
to screen for ovarian cancer
or a fibroid or something else?
The answer to that is no.
Whether she's disabled or not,
the guidelines are now
almost in uniform agreement
about the fact that screening pelvic exam
is unnecessary and probably
does more harm than good.
All right, in our last patient then,
we'll talk about Elizabeth.
She is 28 years of age.
She has a history of cerebral palsy,
sorry about the term wheelchair bound,
she needs a wheelchair,
she uses a wheelchair.
But she also has an issue with epilepsy,
and that is controlled with carbamazepine,
which is an anti-seizure medication.
She's sexually active with one partner.
She wants to use oral contraceptives,
but she's open to using other methods.
And here are the challenges
that we have with Elizabeth.
Can she use oral contraceptives,
given the fact that she
uses an anti-seizure drug
which induces hepatic
enzymes that would make
birth control pills less effective?
Number two, does she need a pelvic exam?
No.
Number three is, how can
we do an IUD insertion
in a woman who needs a wheelchair
and are there any special
sort of accommodations
that we need to make in that circumstance?
So this is the third and
the last of the pathways
that I'll refer to, so she does
not have menstrual problems.
She is sexually active.
And therefore, we have a whole variety
of contraceptive methods
that are available to her,
most of which you've heard about already.
So in going through that
list, the tier one efficacy,
the ones that will work the
best for her, are a copper IUD.
We haven't talked about those much so far
except for emergency contraception.
They work for at least 10 years,
probably closer to 12 years.
But the one thing they do is they do not
make periods lighter, if anything,
they make periods a little heavier.
Not in everyone, but at least
in some patients who use them.
The levonorgestrel IUD
we've already talked about.
That would be a reasonable choice,
as well as a contraceptive implant,
which is a single rod
that goes under the skin
of the upper arm, and it works
for three years, although
there may be some
unpredictable breakthrough bleeding
which is associated with it.
It is the single most effective
reversible contraceptive
that we have.
In addition, we've
already discussed the DMPA
or Depo-Provera.
She could use the contraceptive patch.
I did not include the
contraceptive vaginal ring
because it might be a
little difficult for her
to put in the ring and take it out.
Not always, but that's a possibility.
She could use extended oral contraceptives
or she could use progestin-only pills,
which might be preferred
because of the fact
that they lack estrogen.
But what I wanna finish
up with is this discussion
about the interaction
of anti-epileptic drugs
or anti-seizure drugs and
hormonal contraceptives.
Because I know many of your patients
are not only using those
medications for seizures,
but they might be using them
for a variety of other things.
Oftentimes, psychiatrists think of them
as mood stabilizers, and so they're used
with other medications as well.
So when we have to make
decisions about contraception
in women who have seizure disorders,
our goals are, number one, to make sure
that we're working with
the primary care provider
or the neurologist to make sure
that the seizures are under control.
Number two, we want to make sure
that she's using highly
effective contraception,
because if she has an
unintended pregnancy,
in utero exposure to some of
those anti-seizure drugs is problematic
because some of them are
actually teratogenic.
Mildly so, but they're
nonetheless teratogenic.
And then we wanna
minimize this interaction
between anti-epileptic
drugs and contraceptives,
and they do that, by the way,
by the anti-epileptic drug,
inducing cytochrome P450 in the liver.
When that happens, estrogen is chewed up
much more quickly, the
estrogen levels drop by half,
and the method doesn't work as well
because of the lower blood levels
of both estrogen and progestin.
So here is a listing of the
various anti-epileptic drugs
that are a problem with enzyme induction
that may make hormonal
contraceptives less effective.
I won't read them to you,
but I've indicated in red
the ones that are sort of the worst actors
in terms of making
contraceptives less effective.
On the other hand, there
are an equal number
of anti-seizure medications that
do not induce hepatic enzymes,
and none of these are problematic.
That's why it's a thumbs
up, 'cause none of these
will have any interaction at all
with hormonal contraceptives.
Okay, so how do we
manage that circumstance?
Elizabeth wants to use
birth control pills.
She may be a very very
good candidate for that,
I'm not so worried about the fact
that she needs a wheelchair,
I'm more concerned
about the issue of the interaction
with the carbamazepine.
So her ideal contraceptives
would either be
either of the IUDs.
DMPA is an excellent choice for women
who have seizure disorders because
it not only works really
well and you don't have to
be reinjected every 12
weeks, it actually has
a calming effect on the CNS, and it raises
the seizure threshold.
So women who have seizures,
a seizure problem,
are actually less likely
to experience them
if they use DMPA as their
method of contraception.
Elizabeth can use birth control pills,
we just need to use a higher dose.
So we would use at least a 35 microgram
estrogen birth control pill,
and instead of 21 days on,
seven days off, we would choose
either continuous birth control pills
or what's called 24/4, which is 24 days on
and four days off, which
allows a menstrual period
if Elizabeth wants to do that.
And then, if you're on any
of those enzyme-inducing
anti-seizure drugs, we try to stay away
from the contraceptive patch
or progestin-only pills
because of the fact that the effect
of the anti-seizure
medication on progestins
may drop the blood levels of
progestin to the point where
they're not gonna be effective any longer.
One last thing, let's
assume that Elizabeth
changes her mind.
Now she's interested in
having an IUD inserted,
as we talked about earlier.
So the kinds of things that we think about
in women's healthcare, this actually comes
from a slide set from ACOG,
and you all are expert and
I really don't have to
remind you about this, but
any women's healthcare practice
or family planning
clinic has to be prepared
to be able to help women with transfers.
Ideally, that's gonna happen in a context
where you have an electric table.
San Francisco General,
probably half of our tables
are electric in our clinic.
And of course, we insist on using those
in any case where we're gonna need
to do a wheelchair transfer.
We try really hard not to
do any kind of physical exam
in a wheelchair, including a breast exam.
Unless the patient insists,
you know, I can't, I won't,
it's not a good time for me to do this.
And then we'll do our
best to try to examine
our person in a wheelchair,
that's really tough,
really suboptimal, it's much safer
to try to do a transfer, and you'll have
a much more effective
exam in that circumstance.
Have the patient empty her bladder first,
and then get away from the stirrups,
they usually do not help.
The alternative positions
are much more effective.
And so the kinds of things
that I would think about doing
are to put in a speculum in a side lying
knee-chest position, which
actually will give you
a very very good view of the cervix
without having to put a woman in stirrups,
you literally put the
speculum upside down.
And it's not particularly uncomfortable,
but it gives you an equally good view,
particularly if you have a person
who's in a lateral decubitus position,
what can really help is to have
a medical assistant hold
one leg up, or sometimes
the patient can hold her
own leg up with her arms.
If she can't do that,
then assistant, of course,
has to help with being able to do that.
Another thing that we
do in some circumstances
is to move the patient all the way down
to the end of the table
and do what's called
the diamond position,
and as long as her bottom
is off the edge of the table, it allows
a speculum examination
without the discomfort
of having to use stirrups
in that circumstance.
And Elizabeth might do perfectly
well with her IUD insertion
with one of these
alternative positionings.
So with that, I'll go ahead and stop.
This is the sleeve of our jersey.
And the little uterus and the
few drops of menstrual blood
coming out, but thanks very
much for your attention.
(applause)
- [Female Speaker] Thank you very much.